so we're at the start of what's probably
going to be a very interesting week and
there are
compelling things and funny things going
on one that's funny is funny not because
joe biden
is the be-all end-all of fixing america
or anything like it
but it's funny because it's a sign of
just how terribly the republican party
has performed
even for many republicans over the last
18 months
joe biden's approval rating in texas
among texas voters is higher
than texas's own republican governor
greg abbott if you can imagine the poll
conducted by the university of houston
hobby school of public affairs
has joe biden at a 41 approval rating
in texas whereas the republican governor
greg abbott is only at 39 percent
approval
in the state of texas now there's a
bunch of interesting layers to this
story and i hope to
get get to all of them or at least all
that i'm aware of the first is that
greg abbott is going to be up for
re-election in the year 2022
and there's talk of beto o'rourke
challenging him
we saw texas closer in the november of
2020 presidential election than it's
been in a very long time
and if these numbers remain where joe
biden is more popular than greg
abbott in texas it could be a really
tough re-election
and it could be an opportunity for a
democratic governor to actually win the
state of texas that would be
fascinating to see now second
this confirms that the high approval
that joe biden is experiencing
nationally we saw it at 63 percent
early last week or the week before that
is being supported not just by
democratic approval of joe biden
in blue states but it's also being
supported by higher than
typical approval for a democratic
president
from voters in red states including the
state of texas and then
the third aspect of this is that right
now
at least much of what biden has done and
much of what his approval is riding on
is his coronavirus response i've been
saying
for weeks now just move forward
with the 1.9 trillion covid relief
package
that's been proposed by biden and by
democrats don't negotiate with these bad
faith republicans
let them all vote against it if that's
what they want to do and so far
democrats
are moving in that direction the
approval numbers
for biden overall and on covet response
and the support of the cobit relief bill
to me
signal that republicans are voting
against the bill at their own peril if
that's what they do what i mean by that
is
this coveted relief bill that joe biden
and democrats want
is popular enough with republicans that
if
republican senators and members of
congress all want to oppose it
they are taking on significant political
risk for doing so now one important
caveat about abbott's approval
some republicans in texas don't like
greg abbott because he did do
a mask mandate so it's not all as simple
as
biden has a higher approval because
abbott didn't do enough
there are people upset with abbott in
texas because he didn't do enough
and there are people upset with abbott
because he did too much even though he
did a mask mandate it was basically
toothless
and uh it's sort of like the worst of
both worlds but the point here is that
even in texas
joe biden's approval higher than
republican republican governor greg
abbott's and that's more
evidence that the country is crossing
party lines on what they want to see as
far as covid response
is concerned and if republicans become
attached to
we stood in the way of kovid and we
stood in the way of you getting any
money
it can could continue to massacre them
into 2022 and remember that under donald
trump republicans lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate and the white house
in 2020. they saw georgia go
blue and texas go closer to blue in the
presidential election
and the republican party really is at
risk here and especially now with donald
trump
considering launching this new political
party it is a very
tender situation for the party we'll
talk a little bit more
later about the willingness of the
republican electorate
to abandon the party and to go with
trump we have some new polling
about that but as has been the theme
with the republican party for the last
four years much of this is unforced
errors
this all goes back to if trump had just
let fouchy run the show
had gotten behind guidelines had offered
american flag
masks for republicans to buy and wear he
would have been re-elected republicans
would probably still have the senate now
we're talking about a democratic
president
with a higher approval rating in texas
than the republican governor
unbelievable stuff